no matta welcome to this video so Queens
gambit I really wonder sometimes if you
play nobody like the Queens gambit how
many times in your life do you have that
on the boredom it's probably beyond
beyond what you can imagine that's
probably a huge number night to e4 what
is this really you want to do so much
time early maybe i okayed cannot it's
not totally rubbish just a bit bit
uncommon they're just playing in order
looking moose so what about this I don't
want to trade even more clear about 95
it's not quite clear that helps me a lot
maybe this keeps some pressure on ok i
will a quick decision i was thinking
that maybe this is some quite
interesting for me with this King side
but maybe I'm wrong let's angle towards
that Queen h5 things like that yeah I
have to retreat him if he goes Bishop a6
Queen h5 g6 that Iraqi cannot grab the
exchange it's not working Bishop g5 and
so on after between age five Queen a
tribe g6 Queen edge takes bishop f1
Bishop g5 that should be good for white
uh-huh so not quite clear if it is what
is the point let's go here intending
Bishop g3 queen g5 look G for this kind
of thing the night on c5 is an
interesting p.m. it doesn't really
control anything relevant like this d
foursquare when your opponent c5 at
least at the squares control of course
then these six would be very weak that's
it adds up not a quite fair point by any
case I think that looks like a nice
position Bishop a six I have see for now
okay so if i go here see what is he
trying to do root d for sacrificing the
queen
probably not huh that looks too crazy
but it looks like I mean where is he
going Queen g5 rook g4 looks really nice
for white and if he goes back to e7
queen age five looks very dangerous
I mean okay i can even that maybe i can
even sacrifice on HSN already can I do
that Queen h5 is going back route age 44
made there you can go F 6 that's very
close it's very close but this is this
is totally fine I don't need to
sacrifice a beer named now I have after
this oh wait you can go Queen back and
go back with the Queen Bishop h4 is the
move that I want to get in maybe I have
to go look 24 yeah that looks better
utilizing that pin and keeping bishop
age for all right in the picture after
Queen age 6 ok I can go here right check
the Queen
so
should be f6 is not yet winning it's
very close but not yet okay let's keep
it
but i have it on m6 I'm actually
threatening to sacrifice on g6 but it
has to be on f6 so that it's made
well that's a cool defense
ship f6 should be one I cannot take on
edge seven and it's not made
it's a core defense
cheeks it huh
I can take you 1 and then play like I
not sure what he plays after that to be
honest you have to check first yeah this
move on it was how many to be expected
it's just attacking f2 we are if you
believe it time money it takes pawn
takes amazing it's not an ideal move but
anyway
yeah me neither attack yet like a detect
really badly or he defended like like a
yeah I know I have no words yeah he
defended excellently well maybe both I
don't know still some pressure but
that's a pretty dangerous counter-attack
maybe he's getting some counter-attack
it going quickly
what I want is I want on the D file like
it maybe I can somehow to strike out
there check yeah like this then rook
here oops no that's much better I cannot
go after weather why don't they go to h6
please explain why not why not Queen age
6 ah I really hate that nonsense check
queen age 6 was just winning this game
ah rubbish let's just rubbish funny
thing is that it's still not clear it
just shows how with the position was
before check check I am winning he
actually pawns are far too far too good
check check check check black forfeits
on time okay I just have queen age 6 why
don't why do I go to g5 and this is
crazy i want to check that first check
chance entirely stupid queen age six and
he resigns of course yeah he has no
check no check and it's made on g7 oh he
loses the damn rook so huh okay i really
want to want to see how on earth wasn't
that checkmate letter check I mean it
looked so dangerous so and ok Bishop h4
was winning straight away I didn't see
that over at all I was just thinking
okay let's check meet the guy I was just
thinking about this k and routed to a it
seems that black is much better here the
engine at least gives it like that
and it probably is right I don't think
this is the type of attack where the
engine has a horizon effect that it
doesn't see deep enough it either wins
now in the next couple of moves or it
doesn't and this is the move that that
saves the day that was immensely strong
it was a relatively best continuation
kicks and here is much better this is
for check and that's not the best move
it seems that look yes better just
keeping that tension but okay you cannot
expect chata clipper fect chalice in the
sun in this part of the game going back
and i was thinking something like yah
rook t3 and maybe check the thing is
that i always have that idea so maybe
maybe it's enough counter play it's
equal material after all I'm not a porn
down yeah and at the end okay we it was
a queen h6 would've won check and she
I'll check he should win but it's still
kind of tricky he has to play just one
defense move like king of eight now and
after that all of a sudden things things
get very her after this I'm winning over
27 he has to play rook hm for that check
I guess right that's just about draw
check or maybe you know for black check
and he's got g5 so yeah that's that's
changing point like this and I mean yes
he is a couple of points up already yeah
one pawn but
okay well at least a tense game thanks
for watching